الحياه البريه تتضائل انت بتحب تروح على
البر الله يبشرك بالخير للاسف الحياه
البريه تتضاءل ونحن نصف الكائنات الحيه في
العالم تشهد انخفاضا سريعا في اعدادتها
هذه وفق دراسه حديثه نشرت في مجلات
بيولوجيكل ريفيوز تكشف ان الانخفاضات
الديموغرافيه المستمره بين الحيوانات هي
اكثر اثاره للقلق مما كان يعتقد من بيننا
اكثر من 71
الف تشمل الثدييات وطيور والبرمائيات
وقاموا بتحليله وجد الباحثون ان 48% منها
في تناقص ملحوظ اللافت للنظر ان 33% من
الانواع التي تعتبر غير مهدده من قائمه
الاتحاد الدولي لحفظ الطبيعه تعاني من
انخفاض اعدادها ما يعني انها تتجه لمرحله
الخطر
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات